die wissenschaft von heute ist die
technologie von morgen
edward teller physiker manchmal kriege
ich von zuschauern kommentare in denen
ich gefragt werde warum so viel geld in
wissenschaftliche projekte gesteckt wird
wenn anderswo auf der welt dringendere
probleme unser geld und vor allem unsere
aufmerksamkeit fordern menschen leiden
an krankheiten hunger zu wenig wohnraum
und zu wenig bildung die ozeane werden
verschmutzt und die luft verpestet
regenwälder abgeholzt tierarten
ausgerottet und währenddessen fragen
sich die klügsten köpfe der welt wie wir
zum mars fliegen können oder wie man
autos dazu bringt von alleine zu fahren
und dafür kriegen sie milliarden budgets
es ist also eine berechtigte frage warum
brauchen wir wissenschaft
[Musik]
die internationale raumstation iss mit
circa 140 milliarden euro
vermutlich das teuerste objekt das je
von menschen geschaffen wurde
seit november 2000 ist sie durchgehend
bemannt gewesen und damit das wohl
aufwendigsten experiment das wir als
menschheit je auf die beine gestellt
haben aber sie ist nicht dafür da ein
paar wenigen menschen die möglichkeit zu
geben im weltall herum zu springen auch
wenn das sicherlich mega viel spaß macht
400 kilometer über der erde werden
täglich wissenschaftliche experimente
durchgeführt die unser wissen von uns
selber unserer umwelt und der physik
verbessern
die nasa hat ein buch veröffentlicht in
dem alle vorteile für die menschheit
aufgelistet sind die wir durch forschung
auf und an der iss errungen haben
darunter sind zum beispiel verbesserte
roboterarme die im op-saal helfen
erkenntnisse über knochen und
muskelaufbau oder eine optimierte
wasseraufbereitung für länder in denen
sauberes trinkwasser ein problem ist das
ganze buch ist voll von vorteilen für
uns menschen hier unten auf der erde
und man sollte nicht vergessen dass es
auch große symbolkraft hat sie ist ein
ständiger außenposten der menschheit und
ein internationales großprojekt das es
so noch nie gegeben hat
alleine die tatsache dass die usa und
russland gemeinsam an diesem projekt
arbeiten wäre von nur wenigen
jahrzehnten unbegreifbar gewesen
und das ist nur die raumstation
satelliten im weltall erlauben uns das
wetter und erdbeben vorherzusagen und
per gps zu lokalisieren und über weite
strecken zu kommunizieren
auch wenn es keine leitungen gibt das
ist zum beispiel bei katastrophen
wichtig damit sich helfer orientieren
und mit den menschen vor ort
kommunizieren können klar raumfahrt
tourismus wie im blue origin und
teilweise auch space ex in zukunft
betreiben wollen ist in erster linie ein
spaß für superreiche
aber dieser spaß finanziert die
entwicklung von kostengünstigen raketen
die wiederum für sinnvollere zwecke
genutzt werden
einen ähnlichen effekt sehen wir zum
beispiel in der formel 1 auf der
oberfläche ist der rennsport reine
unterhaltung
aber es gibt einige innovationen die
ursprünglich für formel 1 wagen
entwickelt wurden nach und nach aber den
weg in unsere alltäglichen autos
gefunden haben
dazu gehören zum beispiel die
scheibenbremse und das leichtbaumaterial
carbonfaser die kommentare die ich
erhalte beziehen sich fast immer auf die
raumfahrt
aber ich möchte auch über wissenschaft
im allgemeinen sprechen sie ist
grundstein unserer modernen lebensweise
ohne wissenschaft während wir quasi noch
im mittelalter hätten krankheiten wie
pocken und können uns nicht impfen
die meisten menschen werden täglich
damit beschäftigt lebensmittel
herzustellen oder zu verarbeiten anstatt
dass sie mit ihrem kopf arbeiten und die
schwere arbeit den maschinen überlassen
das heißt nicht dass wissenschaft
perfekt ist wir können uns gerne über
ineffizienz das immer kapitalistischen
akademische system oder elitenbildung
unterhalten aber wissenschaft hilft uns
kranke menschen zu behandeln und zu
heilen
sie hilft uns nahrung günstig zu
produzieren und in betroffene gebiete zu
transportieren und ergebnisse in der
forschung helfen uns dabei größere
trends zu erkennen und ihnen besser
entgegenzuwirken
und auch hier gibt es den effekt dass
hilfreiche innovationen nach unten
durchsickern der drohnen boom in den
vergangenen jahren hat zb dafür gesorgt
dass kleine fluggeräte wesentlich
günstiger und zuverlässiger geworden
sind in afrika kann deswegen gerade die
express lieferung von medikamenten
patrone getestet werden
klar es gibt auch viele probleme auf
dieser welt die erst durch wissenschaft
entstanden sind
klimawandel atombomben und plastik
verschmutzung um nur einige wenige zu
nennen aber an dieser stelle beißt sich
die katze in den schwanz
ohne wissenschaft gäbe es so gut wie
alles nicht was wir heute für
selbstverständlich halten
zwangsläufig ist also fast alles heute
gutes und schlechtes der wissenschaft zu
verdanken
manchmal direkt manchmal indirekt wenn
man der meinung ist dass wir alle besser
dran wären wenn es das alles nicht gäbe
dann gut dann solltest du vielleicht
wirklich gegen wissenschaft sein
man könnte zum aktuellen zeitpunkt
argumentieren dass eine ente
technologisierung für unsere umwelt
wirklich besser wäre aber wissenschaft
heißt neugierig sein erforschen und
verstehen und erst wenn wir etwas
verstehen können wir uns verbessern
deswegen brauchen wir meiner meinung
nach wissenschaft um unsere welt zu
verbessern und unsere zukunft zu
gestalten
aber ich bin ja nicht der einzige und
deswegen habe ich ein paar meiner
freunde und kollegen gefragt warum wir
wissenschaft brauchen
wozu brauchen wir wissenschaft ich würde
sagen vor allen dingen um den drang nach
wissen und die neugierde zu befriedigen
wie etwas funktioniert bzw
wir leben ja gerade in einer zeit in der
der zugang zu informationen und daten so
einfach ist wie noch nie genau wie deren
verbreitung auch wodurch es aus meiner
sicht umso wichtiger wird da sorgsam mit
umzugehen wissenschaft ist wichtig nicht
nur weil wir dadurch die welt besser
verstehen und bessere entscheidungen
treffen können aber auch weil
wissenschaft uns wissenschaftliches
denken also kritisches denken
wissenschaft ist zu uns als gesellschaft
unglaublich wichtig weil wir ja als
gesellschaft einen unabhängigen rahmen
brauchen wenn es darum geht
entscheidungen zu treffen die uns alle
in irgendeiner form betreffen weil das
der einzige weg ist wie wir uns
weiterhin um informationen einzuordnen
um die methodisch und statistisch zu
bewerten und zu gewichten rationale
argumente suchen meinungen von fakten
unterscheiden aber auch mal seine
meinung ändern wer die fakten aus
gelangen deshalb ist wissenschaft zu uns
als gesellschaft unglaublich wichtig und
jetzt fragen wie ich euch warum brauchen
wir wissenschaft warum ist es richtig
dass wir geld für forschung ausgeben
warum ist es wichtig dass wir neugierig
sind und die dinge um uns herum
verstehen schreibt es mir bitte unten in
die kommentare ich bin mega gespannt auf
eure antworten und diskutiere gerne mit
weiß
dieses video wurde unterstützt von mehr
merck ist ein wissenschafts und
technologie unternehmen und möchte uns
alle im rahmen der neugier initiative
neugieriger machen und innovationen und
fortschritt fördern wie neugierig seid
ihr
um das herauszufinden hat merck einen
selbst test erstellt bei mir kam zum
beispiel heraus dass ich einen pionier
bin motivation und erfindungsgeist sind
die elemente meiner neugier einen link
zum neu geht es den ihr auch machen
könnt mit vielen weiteren features und
sogar einer studie zum thema neugier
findet ihr unten in der video
beschreibung viel spaß dabei und wie
immer bleibt neugierig
[Musik]